The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Recall that in our
previous two lectures,
we have been discussing
the concepts of velocity
and acceleration of particles
moving along a curve.
And we had pointed
out originally
that the most natural definition
was in terms of say, i and j,
or i, j, and k components--
in other words,
Cartesian coordinates.
And then we showed
in the last lecture
that tangential and
normal components
form a rather important
system of vectors.
And now, what we
would like to do
is to motivate the use of polar
coordinate types of vectors.
And again, it's
interesting point out
that we could have
introduced polar coordinates
into our course at any
one of a number of times.
In fact, one of the problems
with the traditional
mathematics curriculum was
that, frequently, topics
were put in just for the
sake of filling a chapter.
They fit into the space.
They didn't need any
additional prerequisites,
so we put them in there.
And many a typical traditional
high school algebra
book could have had
the chapters shuffled
with no loss of continuity.
What we're trying to do
in this particular course
is to motivate why
particular concepts would
have been invented if
they had not already
have been invented previously.
In particular, in dealing with
particles moving in a plane
or in space, there
comes a time when
one considers the very important
physical application known
as a central force field.
Now, in a central force
field-- and by the way,
this is where the word polar
coordinates comes up very
naturally, and why
we call today's
lecture "Polar Coordinates."
See, in a central force
field, what we mean
is that the only
force acting happens
to be located at
a fixed position.
And so that the
force of attraction,
no matter where the particle
is-- wherever that particle is,
the force is always
directed along the line,
either towards or away,
depending upon whether it's
attraction or repulsion.
It's always acting this way.
If we're using
Newtonian mechanics,
since the force is proportional
to the acceleration,
it says what?
That a very natural
direction for acceleration
would be along
the direction that
connects the origin--
meaning the location
of the central force--
to the particle.
Well, you see,
once this is done,
it becomes a very
natural thing to say, OK,
if you're going to be talking
about central force fields,
why not introduce new variables?
After all, it seems that
the important thing now,
in measuring the
central force, is
to know how far the
particle is from the force
and also, I suppose, to locate
the position of the particle.
Once you know how
far away it is,
you would like to know what
angle the radius vector makes
with the positive x-axis.
And in this sense,
that would be all
that we would need to
motivate polar coordinates.
Now, you see, once the
motivation is there,
we can always study the
subject independently of
whether the motivation had
ever been given or not.
In other words,
now, we say, look,
it's important to study
polar coordinates.
Why is it important?
Because you want to study
central force fields.
But the structure
of polar coordinates
is going to be the same,
whether we study central force
fields or not.
Then, you see, once we finish
our study of polar coordinates,
then we say, OK,
now, let's go back,
as a particular application,
to central force fields.
At any rate,
without further ado,
let's tackle the subject
of polar coordinates.
Again, many of you may
be very, very familiar
with polar coordinates,
some of you a bit rusty.
To play it safe, I have divided
the study guide in such a way
that there will be two units
devoted to polar coordinates,
but that this one lecture will
cover both of those two units,
that this lecture, as
usual, will be the overview.
And I guess this is the best
you can do with mathematics
beyond a point.
Beyond a certain
point, mathematics
ceases to be a spectator
sport, and you just
have to dirty your hands
with the computations,
and that the basic theory,
as simple as it may seem,
is straightforward.
It's just a case of picking
up the computational know-how
together with a
familiarity so that you
feel at ease with the concepts.
So let's just quickly go
through the highlights
of polar coordinates.
They start off in a very
deceptively simple way.
Namely, given a
point P in the plane,
if we elect to use
Cartesian coordinates,
the point P can be
labeled as x comma y.
On the other hand, using
polar coordinates-- referring
to this diagram, at
least-- one would
tend, as we mentioned before, to
label this point r comma theta,
where r is the distance of
the point from the origin,
and theta the angle that
we're talking about over here.
Notice, by the way, that
there is a very simple set
of formulae by
which we can switch
from one pair of
representations to the other.
For example, to express x and
y in terms of r and theta,
one simply has that x
equals r cosine theta,
y equals r sine theta.
OK.
And conversely, to express r
and theta in terms of x and y,
one has that r squared
equals x squared
plus y squared and the
tan theta is y over x.
By the way, you
might wonder why I
didn't write r equals
the square root of x
squared plus y squared.
The reason I wrote
this is that we're
going to get into some
complications very shortly,
complications which
I shall skim over.
And if you see how
long-winded I am,
skimming over is not going to be
that short, but short relative
to the treatment
that we're going
to give it in the exercises.
There are certain
complications that set in,
because r can be negative.
By the same token,
somebody says,
instead of writing
tan theta equals y
over x, why couldn't
you say that theta
was the inverse tangent y
over x, use the inverse trig
functions?
Remember that the inverse
trig functions require
a principal value domain.
For the tangent that's what?
Between minus pi
over 2 and pi over 2.
And notice that the angle
theta certainly is not
restricted to that range.
Theta could be in the second
quadrant, the third quadrant.
It can wind around.
In other words,
one of the luxuries
about Cartesian coordinates
was that they were terribly
formally stilted.
There were no two ways to
represent the same point.
In the study of
Cartesian coordinates,
one can say, to a point,
position is everything in life,
that once you've
changed the coordinates,
you've changed the point.
For example, there's
no possible way
for the point x comma y to
equal the point, say, 2 comma 3,
unless x equals 2 or y equals 3.
In other words, for
Cartesian coordinates,
the only way to points could
be equal would be if they were
equal coordinate by coordinate.
The complication that sets
in for polar coordinates
is that, unfortunately, this
simple result no longer remains
true.
For example, if I tell you
that the point r_1 comma
theta_1 is equal to the
point r_2 comma theta_2,
it does not imply-- that's a
slash through the arrow here.
This means it's false.
It does not imply that I can
conclude that r_1 equals r:2
and that theta_1 equals theta_2.
To be sure, it's possible
that r_1 equals r_2
and it's possible that
theta 1 equals theta 2,
but it doesn't have to happen.
Well, the nice thing
about mathematics
is that we can
always give examples
to back up what we're saying.
Let's look at a few examples.
Let's look, for example,
at what happens,
if we're using radian
measure, if we replace
the angle by some integral
multiple of 2 pi added
on to that angle.
In other words, let's take
the point r_1 comma theta_1
and compare that point with the
point whose coordinates are r_1
comma theta_1 plus 2k*pi.
Look, the r values
are the same here.
But look at theta_1
and theta_1 plus 2k*pi.
Notice that, unless k is 0,
these are different angles.
It's rather interesting.
I know in high school
this happens a lot.
Youngsters will
tend to say things
like 30 degrees is the
same as 390 degrees.
And in a way, they're right,
except that they say it in such
a way that it's dangerous.
Certainly, one should
not confuse 30 degrees
with 390 degrees.
What one usually means is that
any trigonometric function
of 30 degrees is equal to that
same trigonometric function
of 390 degrees.
In other words, the
technical way of saying it
is that the
trigonometric functions
are periodic with period
2pi in radian measure, 360
degrees in degree measure.
In other words, for example,
using radian measure,
notice that the sine of theta_1
is equal to the sine of theta_1
plus 2*pi*k, where k
is some integer here.
But that theta_1 is unequal
to theta_1 plus 2*pi*k if k is
unequal to 0.
If k is equal to
0, of course, this
happens to be a special case.
You see, the whole
point is that all it
means in terms of
a graph, if you
were to plot the
curve y equals sine x,
it is possible for what?
Many different values of
theta, many different values
of x, to give the
same value of sine x.
What this means, by the way,
in terms of polar coordinates,
is that it certainly makes
a difference whether we talk
about a line making
an angle of 30
degrees with the positive
x-axis or making 390 degrees,
because, you see,
that 390 degrees
seems to indicate that you've
made one full circuit and then
an additional 30 degrees.
As far as position is concerned,
you're in the same place.
But for example, in terms
of fuel consumption,
it uses more fuel, say, to
go through the 390 degrees
than to go through
the 30 degrees.
But at any rate, that's not
the point we want to make here.
The point is, notice in
this particular example
that this is two different
names for the same point.
But we cannot conclude that,
coordinate by coordinate,
the coordinates are equal.
That's not the worst of it.
The worst of it is that
r and/or theta don't even
have to be positive.
Another way of saying that
is they may be negative.
For example, to capitalize on
the idea of vector notation,
what one frequently
does is says,
look, let's talk about
a negative distance.
And by a negative distance,
we'll identify that with sense.
In other words, let's call
this angle here theta.
See, notice, what you're
really saying here
is you're assuming that
the radius vector, when
you're calling this angle theta,
has this particular sense.
Suppose you wanted to
talk about this vector.
Notice that this would be the
right sense if the angle here
happened to be what?
Theta plus pi-- 180
degrees, pi radians.
Now, what you say
is, if you're looking
at this particular point,
notice that with respect
to this vector,
you must go what?
Negative r units--
in other words,
you must move in the opposite
sense of this particular vector
to get to this point.
And again, this is a
touchy enough concept
that we're going to do
this in great detail
in the learning exercises.
But the point is, notice
that r comma theta is
a different name for the same
point as that which is named
by minus r comma theta plus pi.
Do you see that?
Let's look at that one more
time just to make sure.
See, on the one hand, reading
this angle and this distance,
this is r comma theta.
On the other hand, reading
it from this angle,
the value is minus r and
the angle is theta plus pi.
And I'll get a different
piece of chalk in a minute,
because this doesn't seem
to be writing too well.
But let's not worry about
that for the time being.
Let me give you an example.
Look at the curve
whose polar equation is
r equals sine squared theta.
Notice that if theta equals pi
over 6, the sine of pi over 6
is 1/2.
1/2 squared is 1/4.
So notice that r equals
1/4, theta equals pi over 6
satisfies this
particular equation.
Now, notice that another
name for the same point,
using this recipe here, is
minus 1/4 comma 7*pi over 6.
But without even
looking, you should
be able to see that it's
impossible for this value of r
and this value of theta
to satisfy this equation.
In particular, notice
that sine squared
theta can't be negative.
Just by reading this equation,
r can never be negative,
therefore, how can
r equals minus 1/4
possibly satisfy this equation?
And this is where
the big complication
comes in in terms of
simultaneous equations
and what have you.
Here, we have what?
Two different names
for the same point.
Yet, by one of its names, the
point satisfies the equation,
and by another name, it
doesn't satisfy the equation.
And this is a very,
very touchy thing,
because you'd like
to believe what?
That a point belongs to a
curve, not the name of a point.
And that one of the difficulties
with polar coordinates
is that, to check whether
a point belongs to a curve
or not, if the point,
as named by one way,
doesn't satisfy the
equation, you still
have to check other
possible names
to see whether they satisfy
the equation or not.
And this is a very
complicated topic.
And this is why some of our
learning exercises in this unit
take so many pages.
It's more or less devoted to
giving you insight into this
if you don't already
have this insight.
But at any rate, let's continue
on in general terms here.
The next most important
thing to talk about
is to make sure that
we understand what
polar coordinates really mean.
Namely, when someone
says, I am thinking
of the curve C
whose polar equation
is r equals sine theta, he does
not mean plot r versus theta
this way and call that
the curve C. You see,
notice that even though you're
calling this r and theta,
using the axes to be at
right angles this way,
no matter how you
slice it, you're still
using Cartesian
coordinates here,
only what theta replacing
the name of x and r
replacing the name y.
See, this is not what's meant.
Remember that when
you're talking
about polar coordinates, r
specifically measures what?
The distance of the particular
point on C from the origin,
and theta measures the angle
that that radius vector
makes with the x-axis.
For example, what we do
we mean by the curve whose
polar equation is
r equals sine theta
is the circle of radius
1/2 centered on the y-axis,
you see, at the point what?
In Cartesian coordinates,
x is 0, y is 1/2.
And I claim that that's
what we mean by the curve r
equals sine theta.
And how can I prove that to you?
Well, the easiest way
to prove that to you
is by some elementary geometry.
Namely, I call this
point r comma theta.
I now draw in these guidelines.
Notice that, by definition,
this length is r.
Since this is an inscribed
angle on a diameter,
it's a 90-degree angle.
Therefore, since this angle is
theta and both of these angles
are complements of
a 90-degree angle,
this angle must also be theta.
And now, if I just look at
this particular diagram,
I read this right triangle,
and immediately, I see what?
That from this right
triangle, r equals sine theta.
In other words,
the curve C, whose
polar equation is r
equals sine theta,
is this particular curve.
By the way, we often
get indoctrinated
into seeing things in a
very natural way in terms
of a native tongue.
My father-in-law was
brought up in Russia.
He had a little grocery store.
He spoke fluent
English, but when
he added up customers' bills,
he always added in Russian.
He was more at home
with Russia numerals.
And this always impressed
me, until I realized
that I was the same
way, only I use
base 10 numerals instead of
base 7 or something like this.
And the same thing
happens with the polar
versus Cartesian coordinates.
Even though polar
coordinates are
independent of
Cartesian coordinates,
the fact remains that
we're probably more
at home with
Cartesian coordinates
than we are with
polar coordinates.
Consequently, one
very common trick,
when we can get away with it,
is to take a polar equation
and translate it into an
equivalent Cartesian equation.
Namely, given r
equals sine theta,
and remembering that r squared
is x squared plus y squared
and that r sine theta
is y, we multiply
both sides of this equation
by r to get r squared
equals r sin(theta).
This leads to x squared
plus y squared equals y.
If we then complete
the square, et cetera,
we find that, in
Cartesian coordinates,
this is the equation of the
circle centered at the point 0
comma 1/2 with
radius equal to 1/2.
The thing that's very,
very important to note here
is that, in terms of x
and y, the relationship
x squared plus y squared
equals y is not structurally
the same as the relationship
r equals sine theta.
In other words, the
curve C is the same
whether you use
its Cartesian form
or whether you use
its polar form.
But what's very
important to note
is that the relationship
between r and theta
is not algebraically the same
as the relationship between x
and y.
But the important point
is that, since the curve
C does not measure r versus
theta as being at right angles
to each other, that if you
were given r equals sine theta
and you compute dr / d
theta, which, in this case,
simply would be what?
cosine theta-- that does
not have the slope of C.
You see, this is what I
want you to understand.
If I compute dr
/ d theta and one
would interpret that as a slope,
it's not a slope of the curve
C. It's a slope of this
particular curve which wasn't
C. In other words,
this is the curve
that measures r versus theta in
terms of Cartesian coordinates.
That dr / d theta
just shows you how
r is changing with
respect to theta,
it does not tell you how the
curve is rising at that point.
And again, more
information is given
on this in terms of exercises.
But that's what I do
want you to understand.
It does not mean that you can't
compute the slope of this curve
at any point.
It does mean that if
you want the slope
and you compute it by
letting it equal dr / d theta
you will get an answer this
way, but it won't be the slope
that you're looking for.
In fact, what I hope that
you can see rather simply
here is the following.
Say I want the slope
of the tangent line
to the curve at this
particular point,
it doesn't really
make much difference
whether I use the angle phi--
which the tangent line makes
with the positive x-axis-- or
whether I use phi or "phi,"
or, I don't know-- This angle
is called either "phi" or "phi".
And this angle is
called "psi" or "psi."
I get all mixed up
with the Greek letters.
You know, in fact,
coming into work today,
I was listening
to a disc jockey,
and he was making fun of
how in drugstores now, you
can get a full course
meal, but you can't
get any medicines anymore.
And he was talking
about his friend who
got all A's in pharmacy school,
and they flunked him out
because he didn't know
how to make a sandwich.
I almost flunked out of
math because I have trouble
with the Greek alphabet here.
But look, forget about that.
The thing I want
to see is I want
to know the direction
of this line.
If it's convenient to
use phi, I'll use phi.
use psi, I'll use psi.
What is phi?
Phi is the angle
that the tangent line
makes with the positive x-axis.
What is psi?
Psi is the angle
that the tangent line
makes with the radius vector.
Now, as I'll show you in
some of our exercises,
to use the definition
that the slope is
tan phi and translating that
from Cartesian coordinates
into polar coordinates is
a very, very messy job.
What turns out to be
very, very interesting,
at least from my point of view,
is that not only is the angle
psi-- "psi"-- more natural
to use than phi when
you're dealing with
polar coordinates,
but it almost turns out that
because it was more natural,
there's a simpler
formula for it.
In other words, whereas
the formula for tan phi
is very, very complicated
in polar coordinates,
the formula for tan
psi is very simply
given by r divided
by dr / d theta.
In other words, if
I take r, divide
that by dr / d theta, what I get
is the tangent of this angle.
Now, look.
Once I have the
tangent of this angle,
it's very simple to
construct a tangent line.
That's what I want you to see.
Look.
Suppose this is the point
P, and this is my pole O,
for polar coordinates.
And given that r was
some function of theta,
suppose now I've
computed dr / d theta,
I've divided that into r, and
I've now found what tan psi is.
What I do is I take
the line of action that
joins the origin to P, I
construct the angle psi,
draw this line, and
whatever that line is,
that is the line which is
tangent to my particular curve
at the point P.
But the thing I want to
see is that we do not
need Cartesian coordinates
at all in order
to be able to tackle calculus
properties when an equation is
written in polar coordinates.
But what there is a
tendency to do is what?
That when we're dealing
with polar coordinates,
since we're more at
home with Cartesian
coordinates, we will often be
tempted to switch everything
into Cartesian coordinates,
which is perfectly fair game.
But the important
thing is to remember
that all of our calculus results
can be derived independently
of whether Cartesian
coordinates were ever invented.
For example, the
final concept I want
to talk about in this lecture is
how one would have studied area
if one had only polar
coordinates and had never
had Cartesian coordinates.
By the way, notice also that,
in terms of polar coordinates,
one is more
interested in sectors
than in rectangular grids.
In other words, if you look at
something ranging from theta_1
to theta_2, you
think of something
caught between two rays here.
And let's suppose I wanted the
area of this particular region,
where this particular curve
happened to have the form,
say, r equals g of theta--
I don't care what it is.
Let's just call it
r equals g of theta.
Now, the interesting
point, again-- and I
keep saying "interesting
point" because they
are interesting points--
that if you have really
taken Part 1 of this
course seriously,
you're going to be amazed
to see how much free mileage
you get out of Part 2 just
by translating things back
in to our general
theorems of Part 1.
Let me see how I could find the
area of this particular region.
The idea is I'll take a
little increment of area
here between these
two black lines.
Remember, my basic building
blocks are now r values.
What I'll do now is
I'll pick the smallest
value of r that gives me an arc
that lies inside this segment.
then I'll pick the
biggest value of r
that encloses this segment.
Notice, what I do is I'll
let capital R sub capital
M denote this radius.
See, that's this distance
from here to here.
I'll let little r sub little
m represent this distance.
What I'm saying is, if
I now swing two arcs,
my area theorems from
the first semester--
my area axioms from the
first part of course--
are still valid.
Namely, the smaller r--
the smaller sector--
is contained inside the
delta A that I'm looking for.
And the larger sector
contains the region
that I'm looking for.
In other words, the region
that I'm looking for, delta A,
is caught between the
areas of these two sectors.
Now, how do you find
the area of a sector?
What you do is you take the
area of the entire circle
and divide it by the
fractional part of the circle
that you're taking.
For example, the area of the
circle whose radius is capital
R sub M is pi R sub M squared.
Now, what portion of
the circle am I taking?
The angle is delta theta.
I'm using radian measure, so
the entire swinging angle would
have been 2*pi, so I'm
taking delta theta over 2*pi
of the entire circle.
So that's the area
of the larger sector.
What is the area of
the smaller sector?
The area of the
smaller sector is
the area of the entire circle--
pi r sub little m squared--
times, again, what?
Delta theta over 2*pi.
And because the region is
embedded between these two,
its area is caught
between these two areas.
And if I now solve
for the delta A,
I simplify, I cancel the
pi's, I get that delta A is
caught between what?
1/2 capital R sub M squared
delta theta and 1/2 little r
sub m squared delta theta.
I now divide through
by delta theta.
And I make a non-crucial
assumption here
that delta theta is
greater than 0, remembering
that delta theta is negative.
All I have to do is reverse
the signs of the inequalities.
The only reason I assumed
that delta theta was positive
is so that I wouldn't change the
direction of the inequalities.
A similar
demonstration will hold
when delta theta is negative.
The important point is I then
divide through by delta theta.
I get delta A over delta theta.
It's caught between 1/2
little r sub m squared and 1/2
capitalized R sub M squared.
Now, as I let delta theta
approach 0, what does that
mean?
I'm going to let delta
theta close in over here--
approach 0.
What's happening here?
This is a fixed value of r.
Notice that little r sub
m and capital R sub M,
as delta theta
approaches 0, they're
both being pushed
closer and closer to r.
In other words, as delta
theta approaches 0,
r sub little m and
capital R sub M
both approach r, provided that
r is a continuous function
of theta-- in other
words, that there are
no breaks in the curve here.
OK?
The important point,
then, is what?
We can then take the limits
as delta theta approaches 0.
And we find that dA /
d theta is the limit,
as delta theta approaches
0, delta A divided
by delta theta, which
simply is what now?
We come back here.
As delta theta
approaches 0, little r
sub m and capital R
sub M both approach r,
and therefore, this
common limit becomes
1/2 r squared,
therefore integrating
this between what limits?
Between theta_1 and theta_2, I
find that the area of my region
is the integral from theta_1
to theta_2, 1/2 r squared
d theta, which, of
course, means what?
This integral 1/2--
r is g of theta,
so I square that--
times d theta.
And notice that this is a
function of theta alone.
And so I can find
this particular area.
What's crucial to understand
is that the area does not
change just because
you're dealing
with polar coordinates rather
than Cartesian coordinates.
But rather the form of
the equation changes.
What I mean by that is
something like this.
Let's suppose I have
a region like this.
This region is inanimate.
It doesn't know whether you're
looking at in polar coordinates
or in Cartesian coordinates.
In Cartesian coordinates, it's
bounded above by the curve
y equals f_1 of x, and it's
bounded below by the curve
y equals f_2 of x.
From what we studied
in the first semester,
the area of the region r
in Cartesian coordinates
is the integral from 0 to A,
f_1 of x minus f_2 of x, dx.
On the other hand, if I call
this curve r equals g of theta,
in terms of polar coordinates,
and the initial angle is
theta_1, and the terminal
angle here is theta_2,
then the area of
that same region r
is given to be 1/2 integral from
theta_1 to theta_2, g of theta
squared d theta.
Mathematically, this
integral in terms
of x and this integral
in terms of theta
look completely different.
But the crucial point
is they are simply
different expressions
for the same answer.
Which of the two is
the better one to use?
It depends on the
particular problem.
If, for example,
a problem begs for
a polar coordinates
interpretation,
use polar coordinates.
In fact, polar coordinates
and Cartesian coordinates
can both be bad
sets of equations.
Who knows?
It's not the point.
The point is that we now
have two coordinate systems.
There are others that we will
define as the course goes on.
But the important point
is that we are now
ready to tackle motion in the
plane for central force fields
if we so desire.
At this particular
moment, I do so desire.
So the chances are
that next time,
we will be talking about
velocity and acceleration
vectors in polar coordinates.
At any rate, until
next time, good bye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.